welcome to this video playing agent Fox
Mulder
okay from from New Zealand playing the
night off and opening that is not
totally alien to me if you understand
the x5 reference but I don't know it
very well
okay this might it looks a lot like bull
a slovsky's system what takes really
okay
I don't I don't know that opening rhythm
is this if I go with let's say a five
and we get to the end game is this a bad
end game from me mhm I don't think so
okay let's play a five fix the queenside
okay it's not it's not exchanging let's
see just Bishop e7 I guess I don't
really feel at five especially as long
as I have not cancelled
hmm
mmm-hmm just castling yeah I guess so
I mean f5 I have d5 so Alice's cannot be
that great and well he probably will
just develop it should be three
something like that
maybe a flick in this move yeah and yeah
how to play now I can take and maybe try
to relocate my Bishop takes Bishop takes
98 and Bishop f6 is a fairly typical
maneuver
okay maybe Bishop e6 first I'm wondering
20 298 rook e1 Bishop f6 maybe I'm a bit
too later for the D pawn okay he's going
there not to d2 maybe I need to play
Queen c7 look at the eight first maybe
do that
he also maybe he also wants to play
Queen g3 yeah I understand I understand
so here and then Queen g3 coming
I wanted to play knight yet anyway
hmm Bishop should age six but I'm not
sure how bad it really is what I would
like to do is of course Bishop f6 285
this would be excellent get this those
bishops traded interesting position
Bishop h6 would prevent Bishop f6
because of rook takes f6 but after
Bishop h6 are probably just flaking King
edge aide very interesting
takes Bishop takes Bishop d6 route d6
resistance is probably just bad D 595
Naoki I probably must do it it's not
such a bad structure but my pieces are a
bit a bit off I really need 97 I try to
bolster my defenses and I to G 7 that's
let's go with them 94 maybe here no but
okay that's not that's not so dangerous
I guess c5 Knight b5 probably not but
they don't want him to take I can even
consider to take with the pawn here
maybe politics and look f8 coming oh I
see sacrificing quickly on on g6
maybe but the night is generally a good
defender this is a situation we only
need one or two moves to to to to
organize just Luke f8 maybe he can just
take one g6 but with one minute I cannot
really cannot really calculate this till
the end
Bishop g6 I can I can always trade stuff
on on everyone this this should be okay
really he needs to take now and then I
have a good light square blockade yeah
that's nice that's nice for black should
be quite advantageous really but how do
I play Queen maybe invading Queen b6
before yeah the side morning h5 I can
just take this is not not leading too
much
- I want to get this
Queenie for check-in Queenie for check I
can even take on 1 1 C to check if he
moves the King I mean and this wind
stroke so he must play Queen Queen there
and do I have do I have a tactic here
maybe you could g5 pawn takes Queen h4
check between H 2 this is a perpetual at
least I don't mean I'm of course better
but you have this typical time pressure
problem maybe I can
use some tactics Jakes and h6 to get a
good look endgame Luke shakes I take
with check on g5 and then take you five
with a very nice book and game check
still not not easy to why to win okay
yeah that's not easy to win it all but I
can play some quick moves however check
check and I cannot I cannot win this
really well maybe no Charlie no then
there are some chances he gave me check
some ground here check white for things
yeah I mean I can really play this play
the zone with this extra point it's not
totally dead yeah hard to tell I I was
under under some some some pressure here
it's an interesting situation here
maybe Knight h5 was special yeah yeah I
was just thinking okay let's get rid of
this knight on d4 and not looking at
night h5 but this was was more
interesting
yeah this is this is maybe I'm maybe a
bad position Bishop g5 to have success
what the compass are suggesting yeah
that looks indeed quite dangerous
the bishop coming here hmm something
like this no that's good for white
bishop g6 now a very serious possibility
lady threatening to take here in only
six that's very tough two defenders
compass on +1 and it will probably get
higher yeah I should play Knight h5
ready here the worst is probably over
and this is not not helping him at all
yeah here only black can be better just
a question of how much maybe yeah Bishop
is 7 especially attending Bishop edge
from there Queen b6 is probably not the
best possible move I wanted to get get
in with the Queen now h6 winning hmm wow
that's cute yeah yeah okay yeah I look
at this age six I mean this is check
this is easy and yeah if he goes there
yeah check and this is the difficult
thing to see you protect you protect him
and she really has to move check like
just win cm okay yeah I didn't see h6 at
all yeah I was only looking at this
thing yeah here I can play this to to
secure the cat show but I have no win I
think okay I had this idea here with
with Bishop
with bishop to deform okay this is the
engine suggestion right that's very good
that's very good the ideas yeah okay
it's not not so difficult to find but
you need a bit of time after this I go
here and then I'm threatening teenage 7
so that he must play Bishop g5 I'm
basically getting the game position with
yet one more pawn on h5 and okay this is
a easy win okay yeah but I didn't see
that I only saw this this funny idea
completes rook age six now for for a
draw yeah yeah yeah he's too active he
will pick up upon him okay and this is a
check again better for form for me
of course before I shouldn't take I
actually thought I made a misjudgment he
I thought if I take I mean I only had
twenty something seconds but I thought
if I take I would win the c4 pawn but I
don't ID for as much stronger using
using the peso and I have c5 possibly to
cover it
yeah this is much stronger okay well an
interesting game thanks for watching